let's think about let's think about this
exact situation in fact let's go with
boiling pot of water so that's 100
degrees Celsius okay let's go with 80
degrees let's go with 18 feet okay now
that's what I want to know is how what
like what temperature is that what are
going to be after I've taken off the
stove left it in the environment and I
want to know what temperature's going to
be after 10 minutes so okay what I need
is a piece of information I need to know
how quickly is this cooling okay so what
am I do is I could say as an example so
I've got my 100 degree water so I've got
my boiling what I got my 18 degrees as
my ambient temperature okay now
obviously if you've got this as an
actual question you'd have a lot more
details surrounding this and there's
going two parts of lead you into it but
we don't need the beggar to that to work
out what happens after 10 minutes this
is my question what I need as you can
see right having a look at say this
equation here right we know that this is
roughly how it's going to behave but
what we don't know like we know where it
starts I start we know where it goes we
can work out where it's going to start
in a bigger this value but what I don't
know is how quickly things change so I
need some kind of measurement okay so
let's suppose just suppose something
reasonable after two minutes let's
suppose I take a measurement get a
moment up pop it in let's just say it's
70 degrees okay I've got everything I
need now I've got all the conditions of
a need to work out everything about this
and I've got a question that i'm going
to post this what happens after 10
minutes okay now like i said if you got
this is an actual question you guarantee
part a of this question will be to say
show that this equation satisfies this
differential equation because this is
what growth decay is
right this is the normal growth or decay
but this is modified eluates of has some
constraint so Part A will be to see okay
can you do exactly what we just did here
differentiate and show you get the
differential equation out so that's just
a bit a bit sneaky and let's just call
that party okay it's done they always
start that way because you can't justify
using this equation until you showed
cool this demonstrates the
characteristic the key characteristic of
growth or decay it's differential
equation so let's suppose we've done
that as part a and now on to Part B can
we work this thing out okay now we've
got a couple of variables a couple of
constants I should say so than one is
over I want a and I ok ok have a look at
what's on the board what can I use to
work out a because that's the easiest
thing to work yeah when I have time zero
the temperature is known yeah that's one
thing i can do to reverse but it'd be a
lot Messier so what I say when T equals
zero I should take when time equals zero
the temperature equals 100 ok so we've
seen this before this is just
substituting it here right now because
it's modified it's not just this simple
one it's just going to give tiny bit
different so I've got to say okay here's
my actual equation you which are just
straight up at a satisfies the
differential equation and i'm going to
say 18 + AE to them what which in this
case is zero equals the temperature
which I've just defined as 100 okay so
you can see here are if all I want is a
that this becomes a touch one which is a
and I'm just going to make it the
subject so i subtract it from both sides
which is moving a to ya so you can see
another reason why i'm not going to call
that teen or because that is it not in
fact the temperature at time zero right
so i can say therefore T equals 18 + 82
so I take care of a I have one more
constant to evaluate
okay and how am I going to do it what
piece of aphasia okay so i had a type-0
a condition and now i have some
arbitrary time in this case of statute
so I'm going to say yeah i'm going to me
when t equals to the temperature equals
seventy so again i'm just going to go
straight at it all over again something
to go 18 plus a 2 e to the what minus 2
okay good equals and then this is my
temperature that is not that's 70 yeah
so I'm just going to tidy up a little
bit what's that 52 52 I can do a
division because I have a common factor
and what we do at this point because
what am I after what I've after case i'm
at a lot about something that leaves me
with this over here and miss over here
one last up there are 7 i'll get came
out of this I don't really need those
maggots shut up okay now you will notice
by the way at this point excuse me oh
you'll think you might think back on all
my long stuff right I know stuff about
logs I could simplify this if I wanted
to but remember where this is going
remember way that's supposed to fit it's
supposed to fit in here yes this is my
uh my equation for temperature okay not
only like being this is the last concert
I need to evaluate not only this going
to go in them but the actual question
says after 10 minutes okay so therefore
here I can do this all in one here I can
say now when the time is 10 and I'm
going to evaluate everything through
I've said before because this um value
for K which I've left exactly you should
always leave exact
because it's a bit messy some people
will avoid writing it until love of wine
and they have to because they're just
want to avoid right at many times but as
you can see I don't think it's that bad
and you can use it to your advantage
watch I have my equation for temperature
it's 18 + 82 e tumor ok I'm going to
snap it's all them right so first it's
it's minus KT so i do- there's k don't
forget it's got a minus as well by this
k and now what's my going for t 10 yeah
so I've got 1882 okay I've got two
negatives in there which are going to
cancel I've got a half and a 10 so this
is e to the five lon 2641 do you agree
with that now you can reach you a cafe
river that's fine I'm not going to
because I can still do it any bit of
work here just to make this a little bit
need up have a look at this right do you
agree this is either the power of like
think about your index laws this is e to
the power of log 26 on 41 225 do you
agree with that like ass multiplication
of pallet but e to the log x is just x
is or not so i can write this is 18 + 82
times this okay now i just like that a
teeny bit better because it's just less
buttons on my calculator you can push
that through you can make sure you click
the index button so you get your power
than you whatever you want it to be and
you should get a number with a few
decimal places after i can someone give
to me 20 20
I know okay he's on pretty much air I'm
pretty much dance what have we just
established let's conclude this thing
because the question says after 10
minutes okay now one of the cool things
are that actually you guys don't get to
learn generalities do is the way to get
all of these measurements right you see
how they're also the nearest degree
together on to the nearest degree so
that is reasonable enough evidence to
assume that there is like if I've got a
thermometer that the smallest unit on it
was probably one big rig we call that
the limit of reading actually in journal
mats so therefore even though wasn't
given to me and normal question with all
the proper details would I'm going to
round my answer office to the nearest 3
i'm going to assume that the error from
here is going to match the area so i'm
going to say after 10 minutes my border
which was boiling will be 26 degrees and
i'm going to the hollis nearest whole
number because that's what my original
so let's pause and let's think does this
match our intuition that's something
that right is that what you would expect
after 10 minutes you've lost them heck
of a lot of temperature why is that okay
of course because this is exactly what
it's doing I would point out as well how
much how about how much temperature was
lost in the first two minutes 30 degrees
was lost in the space of two minutes in
the ensuing eight minutes between that
time and this time how much temperature
has been lost now
444 TV okay so in other words like not
that different really my failure is for
you is it's in the same ballpark it took
two minutes to only lose to lose that
much and then it took another eight
minutes to go much further why is that
yeah it's slowing down because it's
proportional to its difference to the
environment temperature right and as
that difference gets smaller the whole
the whole fear just slows management